[Musik]
wird Wohnen unbezahlbar kommt die große
Bankenkrise jetzt zu uns und Stichwort
Corona brauchen wir in Deutschland eine
neue Debattenkultur das sind spannende
Themen heute bei 8:15 Uhr mit spannenden
Gästen heute bei uns arztautor und
ehemaliger Leiter eines Gesundheitsamts
Friedrich Pörner nach dem Lauterbach
Eingeständnis zu Impfschäden sagt er
stoppt sofort eine corona-impfungen
CDU-Politiker Christoph Kloss hat im
Bundestag Aussehen gesorgt er kämpft wie
kein anderer für die efuels und will
damit für uns alle das Auto retten große
Bankenkrise in den USA schwappt das auch
zu uns rüber Finanzexperte Christian der
Stadt muss aufhören schlechte Banken zu
retten
Journalist Daniel Gräber blickt besorgt
auf die neue flüchtlingskrise und sagt
zu viele Nutzen unserer Asylgesetz aus
ja und was immer mehr Menschen um den
Schlaf bringt das sind die steigenden
Kosten fürs Wohnen ab 2024 Säure nachdem
der Regierung das Heizen mit Gas und Öl
schrittweise verboten werden die EU hat
jetzt noch eine zwangsanierung obendrauf
gelegt demnach sollen bis 2030 Häuser
mindestens die Energieeffizienzklasse e
erreichen hierzulande betrifft das rund
6 Millionen Wohnhäuser die dafür eine
bessere Dämmung oder ein neues Dach
brauchen das Ziel weniger
Energieverbrauch mehr Schutz fürs Klima
kritiker warnen das macht das Wohnen für
uns alle immer noch teurer 61% haben
jetzt in einer bildumfrage gesagt sie
hätten Angst vor extrem explodierenden
Kosten
Herrn sie leben auf dem Land dann sieh
mal nachgeschaut ob sie zu den sechs
Millionen gehören die sich darüber jetzt
auch Gedanken machen müssen ein neues
Dach eine neue Dämmung oder stehen sie
da gut da
ich werde dazu keine keine Äußerungen
tätigen schon klar gar nicht öffentlich
dieser gar nicht mehr Kompetenzbereich
man sollte über das sprechen wovon man
Ahnung hat
natürlich Köche zu dem Betroffenen das
ist gar keine Frage und ich mache mir da
sehr wohl Gedanken was da gerade
passiert und auch in meinem
Bekanntenkreis und auch in meinen
Familienkreis ist sowas natürlich ein
ein Thema und da wird heftig gerade
darüber nachgedacht wie man das
überhaupt stemmen also finanziell eben
stemmen kann das ist eben ganz genau die
Frage die sich viele jetzt stellen Herr
Gräber in Eigenheim können sich junge
Menschen schon fast gar nicht mehr
leisten junge Familien in manchen Orten
in der Hauptstadt weiß beispielsweise
geht schon fast 50 Prozent des
Nettogehalts für Wohnen für Miete
irgendwie drauf wo soll das denn dann
noch hinführen na ich glaube dass die
Probleme die wir die wir jetzt die jetzt
anfangen da auf uns einzuprasseln von
einer
Klimapolitik die nicht eigentlich nicht
das Ziel verfolgt die globalen
CO2-Emissionen möglichst effizient zu
senken und das heißt auch möglichst
kostengünstig zu senken sondern
stattdessen so Michael ist fast schon
also sozialistische planwirtschaftliche
Vorgaben mit festen Zielen die zu
erreichen sind ich glaube da kommt noch
einiges auf uns zu vor allem an
politischen Problemen ich glaube das ist
auch für die EU noch ein Problem werden
kann ganz genau darüber wollen wir
nämlich auch gleich noch sprechen wie
die ganzen EU-Länder das denn umsetzen
werden aber lassen Sie uns einmal
erstmal über die sprechen die vielleicht
planen ein Haus zu bauen irgendwann mal
das ist ja auch schon kaum mehr stimmbar
es gibt kaum Handwerker die Kosten
explodieren würden sie sowas überhaupt
noch empfehlen ist das überhaupt noch
möglich und dann muss man sich
vielleicht noch Gedanken machen wie ist
die Heizung wie ist das Dach wie ist die
Dämmung also die Frage ob jetzt wohnen
besser im Eigenheim ist oder zur Miete
da gibt es die ganze Bücher darüber und
selbst die sagen da sind weiche Faktoren
sein das ist einem wesentlichen
inzwischen eine Frage des Könnens
geworden das logistisch können auch das
finanziellen Könnens und natürlich auch
ein bisschen eine Frage des Überblicks
also ich bin Mieter hier in Berlin
ansonsten Vermieter hier in Berlin und
in Nordrhein-Westfalen und ich muss da
man versucht ja auch wirklich weil ich
selber verwalte lass ungern andere Leute
an mein Geld und mein Eigentum ich mache
selber man guckt dass man auf dem
aktuellen Stand bleibt aber gerade so in
den letzten Wochen fällt das ein
bisschen schwer das zu ordnen das zu
verfolgen was da so aus der Politik
kommt noch sicher zu sein wo ist jetzt
hier gerade was beschlossen worden wo
hat der Wirtschaftsminister gerade
Eingebung gehabt wo ist im
Koalitionsausschuss wieder
Verhandlungsmasse und da muss man
natürlich sein das fördert Investitionen
selbst wenn man will und kann in keiner
Weise und untergräbt natürlich auch das
Vertrauen in politische Prozesse was
hier doch immer da ist dass wir Bürger
sagen also da muss doch oben irgendwo
ein großer Plan sein und diesen Plan
vermisst man über diesen vielen
Einzelmaßnahmen überschlagen sie haben
gesagt sie sind auch Vermieter was da
irgendwie auch als Vermieter auf Sie
zukommen könnte Wärmepumpen Dach Dämmung
das sind ja auch Kosten die schon
zusammen also ich habe zum Glück äh vor
zehn Jahren größere Sanierung gemacht
mache gerade eine Sanierung und manchmal
ist Timing extrem schwierig manchmal hat
man wirklich dieses Timing Glück und ich
werde niemals sagen ich habe da
irgendwas antizipiert und es sieht so
aus also selber morgen wieder kann sich
morgen wieder eine beziehungsweise ich
habe schon entsprechend energetisch
saniert das ist wirklich dann pures
Glück nur das darf nicht in so eine
Glückssache ausarten Menschen müssen
wissen was sie für Verpflichtung haben
insbesondere auch mit Blick auf
Eigenheimbesitzer stellen sich vor das
Eigenheim ist für viele ein Stück der
Altersvorsorge die haben daneben
natürlich auch noch was angespart jetzt
gehen Menschen in die Rente in diesen
Zeiten und das erste was Sie dann machen
sollen ist gleich erstmal mit dem
zurückgelegten Geld wovon sie die
barrentenlücke stopfen wollen ein neues
Dach oder eine Sanierung sowas nur
Heizung hier das ist über 100000 Euro
das deckt manches ersparte überhaupt gar
nicht wir müssen einfach an der Stelle
finanzielles Thema wir müssen gucken
dass uns bei solchen Themen sich die
Gesellschaft auseinander fliegt wir
haben das gerade angesprochen das
Vertrauen in die Politik Herr plosse in
Straßburg in der EU-Parlament wurde da
343 Stimmen zu 2006 dieser
sanierungszwang beschlossen man fragt
sich da schon wie weit ist Straßburg
eigentlich da noch von der Realität der
Menschen von der Realität der deutschen
entfernt das ist eine sehr berechtigte
Frage weil das wird enorme Kosten
verursachen für die Menschen in
Deutschland aber natürlich auch in
anderen europäischen Ländern und das was
mich bei der ganzen Debatte auch stört
ist das nicht nur das Ziel vorgegeben
wird wir wollen ja alle Klimaschutz ich
würde sagen 90% in Deutschland sagen
natürlich wollen wir die
Klimaschutzziele erreichen und natürlich
brauchen wir auch mehr Klimaschutz aber
gleichzeitig soll vorgegeben werden auf
welchem Wege die Klimaschutzziele
erreicht werden und das ist falsch warum
sollte eine Ölheizung ausgebaut werden
die vor paar Jahren eingebaut wurde
selbst wenn man die klimaneutral
betreiben kann mit klimaneutralen
Kraftstoffen beispielsweise oder warum
soll ich eine Gasheizung ausbauen die
für die die Politik vor paar Jahren noch
geworben hat nur weil man sagt als
Robert Habeck Gasheizung Ölheizung die
will man nicht mehr man will jetzt nur
noch Wärmepumpen und das ist das große
Problem was wir im Moment auch vor allem
mit der ampelkondition haben
dass wir letztlich den Weg von der
Marktwirtschaft in Richtung
Stadtwirtschaft gehen also der Staat
schreibt vor auf welchem Wege die Ziele
erreicht werden und ich bin immer sehr
dafür dass wir dann Wettbewerb haben der
Technologien und dass ich auch die
besten Ansätze dann durchsetzen sollen
und vor allem kann ich staatlich
verordnet werden dass man alle paar
Jahre das Auto wechseln muss die Heizung
wechseln muss oder irgendwas anderes
machen muss viele können im Ganzen schon
gar nicht mehr folgen und fragen sich
einfach was passiert damit mit meinem
Geldbeutel und gleichzeitig fragt man
sich auch dass jemand sie bereits
angesprochen ist das jetzt etwas was in
Deutschland gleich wieder brav umgesetzt
wird werden beispielsweise in der EU
vielleicht Italien oder Griechenland
oder Spanien dann haben Sie dass Sie
alle sofort anfangen neue Dächer überall
zu dämmen und das Ganze umzusetzen oder
sind das am Ende vielleicht mal wieder
wir also ich will jetzt nicht in die
Falle tappen und hier Vorurteile
verbreiten aber man kann sich schon
vorstellen dass sage ich mal in
Süditalien eine Energieeffizienzklasse e
vielleicht etwas
großzügiger ausgelegt wird oder man
diesen Stempel vielleicht doch auf
kreativeren wegen bekommt als bei uns
wenn es der TÜV Nord
hat auch die schönen altstätte Daten
also man stellte sich auch einfach
schwieriger vor hat er solche Vorgaben
überhaupt erstmal umzusetzen und
einhalten zu können und ich meinte jetzt
einfach auch wie strengen sozusagen das
dann kontrolliert wird immer eine Frage
der Umsetzung aber ich halte das ist
genau ein Problem aber ich halte schon
den Weg wie Sie sagen dass der Stadt
detaillierteste Vorgaben macht in
welcher Zeit frisst welche Techniken
noch noch erlaubt sind wie viel wie viel
Prozent an an ähm Energiebedarf dann
noch gedeckt werden soll mit welchen
Anteil erhalte ich für den vollkommen
falschen Weg weil es so schlau ist den
Staat kein EU-Beamter
keinen grünen Politiker kein noch so
schlauer Fachbeamter im
Wirtschaftsministerium oder
klimaschutzministerium ist jetzt auch
heißt ist so schlau dass er das
antizipieren kann was sich am freien
Markt an Kreativität und an Lösungen die
im jeweiligen Einzelfall einfach die
besten effizientesten passendsten sind
herausbildet und deswegen halte ich
diesen Ansatz das so detailliert
vorgeben zu wollen schon einfach von
vorne anfangen auch ziemlich
realitätsfern weil sie können ja den
Leuten nicht sagen da vor paar Jahren
habt ihr euch das Auto gekauft jetzt
sagt die Politik oder der Staat man will
ein anderes Auto bei der Heizung das
gleiche vor paar Jahren hat man gesagt
kauft euch diese Heizung haben die
Bürger das brav gemacht und jetzt sagt
man man will aber eine Wärmepumpe und
gleichzeitig haben wir ja die
Möglichkeit das zeigen ja ganz viele
Forschung dass man die bestehenden
Heizung oder auch die bestehenden Autos
klimafreundlicher oder sogar
klimaneutral machen kann und da fehlt
mir wirklich jegliches Verständnis dass
da im Moment gerade die Ampelkoalition
auch sagt also bitte dann nur die
Technologie setzen und Liebe Bürger
kauft euch bitte eine neue Heizung kauft
euch neues Auto oder was auch immer und
da reden wir schnell über 10.000 Euro
10.000 Euro zehntausende
Jahrzehntausende also mehrere
entspricht dann darf man schon wie sie
im hunderttausender Bereich Ansetzen
der das normalen Bürgers ganz einfach
übersteigen und was wir dann passieren
die werden das verkaufen müssen die
Immobilie und da gebe ich Ihnen
vollkommen recht ähm das wird zu einer
weiteren Spaltung in der Gesellschaft
führen und zu einer weiteren
Politikverdrossenheit denn das was
gerade die Politik macht das kann der
normale Bürger schlicht und ergreifend
nicht mehr nachvollziehen ja oder am
schlimmsten wird dann wenn ich gerade
noch einkaufen darf wird es ja dann
immer dann ist ja sehr beliebt jetzt
momentan der Ausblick na da muss der
Staat halt einspringen und mit
Förderprogramm
da frage ich mich wohin soll das denn am
Ende führen also erstmal ist so viel
Geld dass wir jetzt dass der Staat und
das sind letztendlich auch wir
Steuerzahler der Staat oder die
künftigen wenn es Schulden sind dass der
jetzt jedem Einfamilienhaus Besitzer
neues Dach und eine teure Wärmepumpe
dorthin stellen kann und dann vielleicht
noch ein Elektroauto bezuschussen das
wird einfach nicht nicht funktionieren
aber selbst wenn es funktioniert will
ich in so einer Gesellschaft auch nicht
leben wo ich quasi sowas zugeteilt
bekomme dann ist es ja auch immer der
Steuerzahler das ist ja auch finanziert
werden
die dann entscheiden und ihren Stempel
machen ob ich jetzt mein Auto bekomme
oder nicht und das ist die DDR wieder in
diesmal unter grünen Vorzeichen und ich
finde das ich finde das ganz schlimm die
Entwicklung am Ende wer soll das Ganze
bezahlen Sie uns angesprochen natürlich
der Steuerzahler sie sind Mieter und
auch fair Mieter wer wird da dann am
Ende bezahlen willst einfach keiner mehr
ein Haus besitzen oder werden Sie als
Mieter so viel tragen dass die Miete
kaum mehr bezahlbar ist wo sehen sie da
den Schwerpunkt
ich freue mich natürlich
Immobilien zu besitzen und bin sehr
stolz darauf dass ich das was mein
Großvater gebaut hat nun in dieser Zeit
besitzen darf und sehe das auch als
Verpflichtung an hier bezahlbaren
Wohnraum zum Beispiel eine
Hochschulstadt wie Aachen anzubieten bin
stolz darauf dass wir das nochmal
miteinander keine luxus-sanierung
sondern die sich einfach zwei junge
Menschen die zusammenziehen und an der
Uni arbeiten ist wissenschaftliche
Mitarbeiter das sind so unsere Mieter
dass sie das dass sie das machen können
ja und ich habe auch ich habe auch
nichts dagegen ist noch nicht unbedingt
sondern Rendite Thema ja nur für sich
dafür möchte ich möchte Kleid haben was
wird von mir erwartet ich möchte kein
Bashing dafür haben ja also dieses
dieses Vermieter Bashing und Investoren
was von einigen Seiten in der Politik
kommt finde ich extrem schade auch in
der in der Gesellschaft von einigen
Verbänden denn Dinge funktionieren nur
wenn der Kapital das in Deutschland
übrigens vorhanden ist mobilisieren aber
das braucht eben Sicherheit und das
braucht vielleicht auch mal eines eine
Vision also ich bin ganz ganz weit weg
davon Politik zu kritisieren ich glaube
gerade in diesen Zeiten dr plossy und
ihre Kollegen egal ob jetzt in der
Opposition oder insbesondere auch in der
Regierung die haben einen Job den ganz
viele von uns nicht machen wollen weil
wir gucken lieber da wo wir keine
Kompromisse machen können wo wir in der
Wirtschaft voll durchziehen können das
ist das ist gebe ich alles so aber was
mir halt einfach fehlt ist irgendwie so
dieser drei Schritt den man auch bei
Unternehmen hat wenn es um eine neue
Strategie geht wenn es darum geht
Aktionäre Kunden Stakeholder wie man
heute so schön sagt mitzunehmen dass man
eine Vision entwickelt dass man diese
Vision runterbricht in eine Kette von
einzelnen Maßnahmen die auch irgendwie
zusammenhängen und wo nicht jeden Tag
irgendwer was anderes rausdrückst und
man gar nicht weiß ist das eine Maßnahme
oder nur ein Vorschlag und drittens wo
dann auch mal milestones dranhängen die
man erreichen möchte und wo auch klar
ist wenn man diese milestones nicht
erreicht was passiert denn dann hier in
Berlin werden beim Thema Bauen sind Herr
Geisel hat sich vor einigen Jahren
hingestellt und hat gesagt naja also
30.000 Wohnungen im Jahr das ist jetzt
keine rocket science das schaffen wir
schon das haben wir nie geschafft egal
ob Herr Geißel jetzt Bausenator war oder
hinter der Insel interessant
raus das brauchen wir ja aber was
passiert denn wenn man den malst du
nicht erreichen wie justieren wird denn
danach ja irgendwelche wenn dann das
fehlt mir einfach stattdessen hat man
einen Eindruck ist wird irgendwie von
Bürokraten was gegeben und das muss dann
umgesetzt werden und das ist so ein
bisschen auch und dann kommen wir zu
Ihrem Thema ein bisschen der den
Eindruck den viele auch in der
corona-krise haben da wurde was
beschlossen und da gab es keine Vision
und das wurde vor allem jetzt noch
einmal deutlich man muss sagen sie
ehemaliger Leiter eines Gesundheitsamt
mit der starken Vermutung der stecken
sie auch noch richtig tief drin im Thema
dass sie als Kritiker der ersten Stunde
der corona-maßnahmen ihre Position damit
auch verloren haben jetzt haben wir den
Gesundheitsminister in dieser Woche
gesehen der plötzlich eine Kehrtwende
hinlegt und auf Impfschäden der
aufmerksam macht obwohl er ja zuvor
gesagt hat die Impfung ist
nebenwirkungsfrei für sie ist das ganz
klar der Punkt an dem sie sagen jetzt
jetzt muss man die corona-impfungen
wirklich stoppen und das ist heute hier
ihr Thema ihre Zeit ja vielen Dank also
nach den aktuellen Aussagen von Karl
Lauterbach muss die Kuh mit Impfung nun
endgültig gestoppt werden ganz einfach
warum die von Karl Lauterbach genannten
Zahlen geben wirklich Grund zu Sorge er
gibt dir an das ungefähr bei rund wenn
man das jetzt nachrechnet was er gesagt
hat er rund 20.000 schwere Fälle von
Nebenwirkungen vorliegen und einfach mal
ins Verhältnis zu setzen und jetzt bitte
nicht gleich aufsteigen wenn es das Wort
konnte gar nicht in den Mund nehmen aber
man muss sich einfach mal überlegen als
wir konnten als das war waren das 3000
in Deutschland nun gehen wir von
ungefähr 20.000 Fällen oder von schweren
nebenwirkungsfällen aus laut Karl
Lauterbach
der kalauerbach hat leider Gottes des
Vertrauen der Bevölkerung und auch der
Institutionen hier in Deutschland stark
beschädigt ob das RKI PI die sticko und
natürlich das
Bundesgesundheitsministerium und er
behauptet weiterhin und hat Unwahrheiten
behauptet bezüglich der Impfung und hat
somit natürlich die Gefährlichkeit die
der Impfung verharmlost und deshalb ist
ganz klar mein Fazit und mein Appell an
Herrn Lauterbach heute und hier bitte
treten Sie zurück übernehmen sie
Verantwortung und entschuldigen Sie sich
bei den Bürgern
das heute ihr Appell wir haben das
Interview mit Karl Lauterbach gesehen
das hat für viel Aufregung gesorgt in
dieser Woche was stellt sie an diesem
Interview an dieser Kehrtwende besonders
uns sie haben auch starke Zweifel haben
sie gerade dargelegt an den Zahlen die
der Gesundheitsminister da genannt hat
also mich stört alles an dem Interview
weiß hin und vorne nicht echt ist daher
Lauterbach der benutzt die sogenannte
Salamitaktik ergibt nur das zu ihr
Räumen nur dass ein ähm was nun bekannt
ist jetzt liegen die Karten auf dem
Tisch es zeigt sich
regelmäßig dass die Impfschäden doch
höher liegen als man eigentlich
ursprünglich angenommen hat und nun
endlich
liegt er das in einem Interview da und
und möchte dann auch noch irgendwas
gründen um den Menschen zu helfen er ist
tief betroffen er findet es ganz
schrecklich
er sagt aber auch all die Zeit hatte
über die Zahlen Bescheid gewusst also
ich z.B weiß nicht wie jetzt auf die
Zahl eins zehntausend kommt man kann ja
mal den Preis sicherheitsberichten
nachlesen da stehen die
Verdachtsmeldungen drin und es werden
drei
von 10.000 aber wenn der Lauterbach als
Gesundheitsminister sagt es sind eins zu
zehntausend dann muss man davon ausgehen
dass er da Kenntnis hat und
das ist viel wenn man sich das
hochrechnet an den verimpften
Einzeldosen dann sind es rund 20.000
Menschen und das ganze Interview galt
einfach nur in meinen Augen einer
Vorbereitung dass der Bürger jetzt
langsam aber sicher darauf hin
getrimmt werden soll auf die auf die
schreckliche Botschaft das immer mehr
Impfschäden kommen werden wie sagten sie
gerade paul Ehrlich Institut muss ich
hier noch einmal werden
sie immer noch sagen Sie Herr Klaus wenn
Sie das hören sie haben auch das
Interview gesehen mit dem
Gesundheitsminister das ist eine ganz
schöne kehrt wenn jetzt sind die Sorgen
sehr groß und auch dass die Frage
Zeichen dahinter warum heißt es erst
nebenwirkungsfrei und jetzt dieses
Eingeständnis hier ist von Salami die
rede ja der Karl Lauterbach hat das
Thema völlig unterschätzt und hat die
Sorgen die ja auch schon vor einiger
Zeit da waren überhaupt nicht ernst
genommen sondern beiseite gewischt
teilweise ja noch sogar Sprüche gemacht
in Richtung derjenigen die
Ängste und Sorge haben die ich auch
völlig inakzeptabel empfunden habe und
da gilt wirklich einiges aufzuarbeiten
das beste Mittel um eine Änderung im
Gesundheitsministerium herbeizuführen
ist CDU zu wählen denn wir hätten der
alternativen ja oh Gott bitte das ist
also
die beste Alternative wäre wenn
Institutionen frei werden
ja ohne irgendeine politischen
Schnickschnack ohne dass er
Gesundheitsminister irgendwo sitzt und
dem RKI der sticko oder die mit dem Hai
in irgendeiner Art und Weise vorsteht
diese Institutionen müssen frei und
unabhängig sein denn das RKI der
rki-chef dient dem Gesundheitsminister
das ist relativ einfach ist die
Systematik im behördenwesen und deshalb
ist es vollkommen egal wer dort dort
sitzt ich meine hinterher sparende
Vorgänger vom Herr Lauterbach wenn ich
ihn auch enttäuscht ich glaube der war
bei der CDU oder ist noch bei der CDU
sie sich das richtig schon paar
rhetorische Frage also bitte der hat
diese Verträge abgeschlossen mit den
Pharmafirmen er hat sie von der Haftung
entlassen
weil das ist in der Zeit geschehen als
alle gesagt haben wir brauchen dringend
mehr Impfstoff nein das ist nicht
richtig
reden nein
haben sie recht wenn sie sagen die
Experten die gehört werden wollten
Bundesregierung
es gab eine sehr sehr große Mehrheit im
Land wenn man sich damals an die
Diskussion erinnert auch die
Bild-Zeitung hat gesagt endlich brauchen
wir den impfturbo und die im Schnecke
die muss dringend mehr Impfstoffe
bekommen also Deutschland wurde als im
Schnecke bezeichnet und es gab von ganz
ganz vielen Seiten die Forderung endlich
mehr Impfstoffe zu beschaffen und da
auch pragmatisch zu handeln und wenn man
jetzt paar Jahre später sagt er damals
hätte man so machen sollen und so ich
bin völlig dafür auch aus dieser Zeit zu
lernen und zu analysieren was muss in
Zukunft besser laufen aber man macht
sich auch ein bisschen einfach wenn man
jetzt sagt also ich wusste alles schon
besser und die haben damals den Fehler
gemacht und da da wurde unter Hochdruck
gehandelt man musste in teilweise
Stundentakt enorm wichtige Entscheidung
fällen und natürlich würde man zwei drei
Jahre später manches anders machen aber
jetzt zu sagen also Jens Spahn der hat
da alles falsch gemacht da muss ich
wirklich
widersprechenden vollkommen zu das war
außergewöhnliche Situation aber man hat
den Fehler gemacht man hat nicht auf die
Kritiker gehört und da werden sie mir
doch ganz sicher Recht geben die Frau
Merkel und nach der Herr Spanien die
haben sich genau diese Experten geholt
die das Lied von denen gesungen haben
das war so ein andere Kritiker die
einfach mal gesagt haben bitte langsam
egal um welche Maßnahmen sind in der
corona-pandemie gab die wurden schlicht
und ergreifen nicht gehört und wurden
sie mal ganz kurz gehört dann wurden sie
anschließend niedergemacht ja
auf die Kritiker da als auch sie haben
ja früher eine Impfpflicht plädiert
würden sie das jetzt anders sehen ich
habe nicht gesagt wir brauchen
grundsätzlich eine Impfpflicht hat
gesagt ich habe ich habe im Bundestag
wir brauchen eine sondersitze um darüber
zu entscheiden und das zu debattieren
weil das damals ja eine sehr dringende
Debatte im ganzen Land war aber ich habe
gesagt in der damaligen Zeit heute finde
ich ist eine Impfpflicht überhaupt nicht
angemessen der damaligen Zeit wenn wir
sicherstellen können dass mit einer
Impfpflicht ist keine weiteren lockdowns
gibt die ja enorme Kollateralschäden
verursacht haben dann gibt es Argumente
für eine Impfpflicht aber natürlich ist
das ein Mittel was man wirklich nur in
ganz extremen Situation heranziehen kann
aber ich will noch mal ganz kurz die
Frage beantworten weil das in der Tat
sehr sehr spannend ist und ich bin
völlig frei davon zu sagen also wir als
CDU oder die verantwortlichen Politiker
die haben immer alles richtig gemacht
natürlich mit heutigen Wissen würde mal
einiges anders machen
oder absolut richtig damals war das für
mich persönlich auch noch kein Thema und
wie konntest das ist ja aber ich will
ganz kurz die Feier einmal beantworten
also wir hatten zu Beginn der
corona-krise gab es von 95 Prozent der
Menschen im Land gibt ja repräsentative
Umfragen die Forderung harte lockdowns
einzuführen da gab es eher die Kritik
man habe nicht schnell genug reagiert
man hätte noch härter reagieren müssen
war wirklich auch von ganz vielen Medien
inklusive der Bild-Zeitung überall
gefordert worden und irgendwann hat sich
das natürlich umgedreht und die
entscheidende Frage war immer wann
bekommt man den Wechsel hin also von den
lockdowns die am Anfang berechtigt waren
wieder hin zu einer liberalen oder wenn
man so will normalen Gesellschaft und
genau diesen Moment zu erwischen das ist
nicht so einfach und natürlich weiß man
im Nachhinein immer besser wann ist der
geeignete Moment worauf hätte man achten
sollen jetzt in der Bundeswehr
beispielsweise geht weiterhin die
Impfpflicht würden sie das jetzt heute
stand jetzt mit dem Wissen jetzt
ich bin ich bin nicht mehr für eine im
Moment halte ich das nicht für notwendig
hat sich über ihre
sich verändert
eigentlich eigentlich nicht ich habe der
ganzen Sache schon von der Anfang an so
ein bisschen
kritisch gegenüber gestanden weil ich
einfach vieles ich übertrieben fand
durch konnte natürlich auch manches gar
nicht beurteilen wir sinnvoll ist aber
mich hat vor allem gestört dieser
ungemeine Druck der aufgebaut wurde und
wenn sie jetzt sogar sagen dieser Druck
war sogar für die Politik
handlungsleiten dann finde ich das
alarmierend weil ich möchte nicht dass
solche Maßnahmen wie das junge gesunde
Männer wie z.B der Fußballer wie hieß
der vorgeführt wurde also an seiner
Stelle jungen gesund Spitzensportler an
seiner Stelle hätte ich mich auch
gefragt ob ich mich mit so einem
Impfstoff der vielleicht ältere wirklich
schützt und für die sinnvoll ist aber
für ihn jetzt der Faktor vielleicht
wirklich nicht notwendig war muss es
seine eigene Entscheidung sein und wie
Daten Druck auf ihn gemacht wurde das
fand ich fand ich einfach unmöglich ja
Kimmich man muss immer überlegen wie
viel junge Menschen sich aufgrund des
Druckes
impfen haben lassen die einfach wieder
frei sein wollten und dann kam das
unsägliche 2G ja und da kann sich keiner
frei sprechen da kann sich keiner davon
freisprechen der hier Verantwortung
getragen hat und das ist ja nichts
anderes als eine Impfpflicht durch die
Hintertür und dann kam tatsächlich noch
die Impfpflicht und wie viel haben denn
da dafür gestimmt und zwar tatsächlich
teilweise ohne wirklich ja die sektorale
Impfpflicht ja aber Herr Lauterbach war
z.B ja für die komplette Impfpflicht
aber trotzdem wie viel haben den
Politiker im Bundestag mitgestimmt und
ich bin mir ganz sicher nicht alle waren
ausreichend informiert was das überhaupt
bedeutet und wenn sie jetzt sagen so
naja also ich konnte nicht um wissen
dass er Impfung Nebenwirkungen hat oder
wie gesagt aber auf jeden Fall damals
nicht das Thema nein also warum nicht
genau ich finde man muss immer noch mal
dran erinnern in welcher Situation waren
wir damals ganz viele hatten Angst es
gab auch enorm Druck
in der gesamten Gesellschaft wenn jetzt
nicht gehandelt wird wenn es zum
Beispiel nicht zu lockdowns kommt dann
verbreitet sich das Virus es gibt
tausende oder hunderttausende tote wir
wussten das damals ja alle noch nicht
deswegen finde ich es jetzt auch etwas
einfach wenn man sagt also damals was
ist das falsch gelaufen oder das ist
falsch gelaufen
Punkt sie sprechen ja berechtigte Themen
an ich will die gar nicht hier vom Tisch
wischen die muss man jetzt analysieren
und sagen was hätten wir mit heutigen
Wissen anders gemacht und woraus können
wir lernen wenn in der Zukunft wieder so
etwas ist da bin ich völlig bei
Facebook
gelaufen ne natürlich auch dann die
Politik muss ich hinterfragen unter
Lauterbach muss besonders hinterfragt
werden weil natürlich hat er viele
Fehler gemacht
aber
jeder genau man muss man muss man muss
gucken was kann man dann in der Zukunft
anders machen das finde ich es wichtig
die Gesellschaft kann und muss darauf
sein auf jeden Fall nichts vom Tisch
wischen das haben sie auch gerade gesagt
man muss diese Debatte führen auch dass
wir gestern hier an dieser Stelle
versucht mit der Manfred Lutz schauen
wir einmal noch mal rein wie das
ausgegangen ist
wir sehen doch heute das ist doch
totaler Quatsch gewesen und so eine
Impfung
aber wirklich Unsinn ist
ein großer Unterschied
sagen Lauterbach kann das einfach mal
sagen es ist ein falsches Wort
verlässt die Sendung glaube ich
das ist sehr schade bleiben Sie bei uns
nein ja so ging das gestern aus diese
Debatte wurde geführt und war dann ganz
schnell auch beendet wobei wir haben
hier in diesem Tisch dann eben nicht
mehr in vollzähliger Besetzung weiter
diskutiert haben diese Debatte geführt
und das wollen wir auch heute tun denn
wir glauben schon es gibt so haben wir
hier in diesem Tisch auf festgestellt
ein Riss in der Gesellschaft und
vielleicht auch den Drang nach einer
neuen nach einer offenen nach einer
transparenten Debattenkultur sie haben
gerade auch da
verloren ich meine das eine Gesellschaft
dievertiert ist doch total wichtig und
ähm also Meinungen die jetzt sich auf
dem Boden unserer freiheitlichen
demokratischen Grundordnung bewegen ja
die wollen wir doch zunächst mal anhören
die wollen wir nicht abqualifizieren und
ich bin jetzt also überhaupt nicht
irgendwie den hobby-virologen Spielen
ich fand das sehr sympathisch was sie
eben zum Thema Bauen gesagt haben das
kann ich hier genauso sagen ich muss
sagen ich bin dreimal geimpfte ich bin
sehr dafür gewesen ich habe höchsten
Respekt vor allen Entscheidungsträgern
damals vor allen Dingen 2020 mit so
einer unbekannten Situation zu agieren
aber natürlich ist es doch in der
Bevölkerung ganz vieles Gefühl dass hier
irgendwo was schief gelaufen ist und
jetzt wird darüber diskutiert oder auch
nicht warum nehmen wir nicht ein Forum
dafür wie ein parlamentarischen
Untersuchungsausschuss warum gehen Sie
mit Ihren Kollegen in allen Fraktionen
würden sie auch die heutigen
Regierungsparteien nehmen dürfen den
einiger ihr Koalitionspartner damals war
nicht hin und sagen okay das sind die
Themen die wir wirklich untersuchen Mann
wir können nicht alles untersuchen aber
dass wir wirklich drei vier fünf Themen
untersuchen zum Gegenstand eines
Untersuchungsausschusses der wird nichts
ändern wir haben das präventionsparadox
und alles fein wir hatten
Untersuchungsausschuss beispielsweise zu
Wirecard der hat Wirecard auch nicht
lebendig gemacht der hat auch nicht dazu
geführt dass Leute ihr Geld wieder
bekommen aber der hat manches aufgedeckt
das haben großartige Abgeordnete sich
hier als Aufklärer
betätigt wieder dann der Bayer ist wie
bei ihnen der Matthias Hauer in der
Fraktion wieder Florian Tonka jetzt
Staatssekretär da ist auch ein
Sternstunde des Parlamentarismus gewesen
warum nicht diese parlamentarische
Aufklärung wir haben ja als
cdu/csu-fraktion genau das gefordert das
ist dieser Aufklärung geben muss im
Parlament auch in den zuständigen
Fachausschüssen das können wir nicht im
gesamten Bundestag machen sondern es
müssen vor allem dann die Fachpolitiker
übernehmen genau das haben wir gefordert
und da hat leider die Regierung im
Moment gebremst und wir sind auch bereit
unsere selbstkritisch zu stellen also
keiner kann der politisch Verantwortung
getragen hat für mehrere Jahre oder
längeren Zeitraum sagen ich habe nie
einen Fehler gemacht das ist ja völlig
klar mir geht's aber eher darum dass
unser die Fehler muss man dann
analysieren auch benennen und dann
Schlussfolgerung für die Zukunft ziehen
und damit wir uns insgesamt
das haben wir gestern versucht habe ich
gerade in der Turner in dieser Szene aus
der gestrigen Sendung die sie auch
gesehen haben weil ich das noch mal
veranschaulichen glauben sie wir müssen
wieder mehr dazu zurückkommen auch
Brücken zu bauen die Debatte miteinander
zu führen einander zuzuhören und uns
aussprechen zu lassen und vielleicht
auch andere Meinungen mal aushalten
sollen ja natürlich muss man
was gestern passiert ist das ist ja
insofern wirklich tragisch weil der der
der Teilnehmer von gestern der hat
irgendwann einmal gesagt ich glaube es
ist irgendwie die die
Pflicht eines eines guten
also die die christliche Pflicht sich
impfen zu lassen das ist ja schon
Wahnsinn wenn man sowas wie man sowas
von sich gibt und natürlich bin ich der
Meinung dass wir wieder Brücken bauen
müssen und mir widerstrebt sowohl die
eine extreme Seite ja die immer noch
rumrennt und sagt wir brauchen unbedingt
Masken wir brauchen immer noch
Impfpflicht mir widerstrebt ganz brutal
dass immer noch Druck aufgebaut wird und
da reicht einfach ein Blick in die in
die stickoempfehlung hinein wer immer
noch geimpft werden soll ja zum Beispiel
Kinder ab 6 Monate bis zum 5 lebensjahr
bei denen wird nicht explizit die
Impfung empfohlen aber wenn Sie zum
Beispiel vorher krank sind oder aber
wenn in ihrem Umfeld jemand ist der wohl
ist
was bedeutet es im Umkehrschluss man
macht den Eltern quasi eine mordsmäßige
schuld wenn sie das Kind nicht impfen
lassen denn wenn die Oma tatsächlich
kombit bekommt und erkrankt schwer wer
wird denn wohl dann den schuldbeutel auf
sich tragen das Kind und die Eltern sie
sind ja auch selbst Arzt ist das auch
eine Kritik ein bisschen in ihrer
eigenen Zunft die erste gefragt sind die
Aufklärung vollkommen unreflektiert
haben die Ärzte geimpft und ich weiß
selbst und den Vorwurf müssen sich die
Leute gefallen lassen die sind in die
Impfzentren gegangen haben sich zum Teil
im Krankenhaus Urlaub genommen damit
sind Impfzentren arbeiten können weil
sie erhalten Geld verdient haben und
haben völlig unreflektiert diese Impfung
reingedroschen und das darf einfach
nicht mehr sein aber wir waren jetzt
beim Thema wir geben uns die Hände und
wir wir drücken ja also ich will aber
auch nicht das andere Extrem und dafür
werde ich auch immer wieder geschalten
in verschiedenen Interviews wenn ich
sage bitte nehmt Abstand von dem Wort
Giftspritze das wird auch jetzt wieder
so sein Ich höre es richtig wie das
jetzt wie die wie die aufschreien aber
tatsächlich es ist keine
Giftspritze ja und wenn man so
diskutiert und so argumentiert dann wird
man die Menschen nicht erreichen dann
wird man auch keinen Konsens finden was
ich ankreide ist einmal diese Pflicht
und der Druck der aufgebaut worden ist
und jetzt einfach
dieses wegschauen von diesen Impfschäden
aber irgendwo werden wir uns doch
hoffentlich treffen können und sagen da
muss man aufarbeiten
es ist eine Impfung ja ich sage nach wie
vor das Wort Impfung das ist so
mittlerweile muss ich tatsächlich sagen
ich kann sie nicht mehr empfehlen für
keine mehr bei mir die Risiko Signale
viel zu hoch sind ganz am Anfang habe
ich sie empfohlen bei bei Menschen bis
60 und mit feuerkrankungen ja aber im
empfehlen und empfehlen bedeutet nicht
Druck ausüben und da irgendwo drin muss
man sich wieder treffen aber es darf
nicht sein dass die Kritiker wenn man
einfach nur sagt ich bin der Impfung
stehe ich etwas kritisch gegenüber was
war man dann Nazi
Leugner Corona Leugner impf Ablehner ja
das ist ja vollkommen aus das habe ich
mir zum Beispiel nie zu eigen gemacht
dass sie aber sie kennen doch die
Diskussionen
ernst nehmen ich bin da auch völlig bei
ihnen es ist schlecht wenn wir sagen man
ist entweder für das eine extreme für
das andere ich finde man muss die Sorgen
ernst nehmen und in der Tat hätte man am
Anfang der corona-krise und als die
Impfstoffe auf dem Markt kam im
Nachhinein viel stärker auch diese
Sorgen ernst nehmen müssen auch in der
gesamten öffentlichen Debatte das etwas
was Politik aber auch Medien aufarbeiten
müssen und umgekehrt ist es auch völlig
falsch alle zu vertrauen die sich impfen
lassen es gibt ja umgekehrt auch
diejenigen die sagen ja wir wollen wir
gehen auf viel los die fürs impfen
wärmen oder die sich selber impfen
lassen wollen ja auch das ist falsch und
deswegen bin ich genau ihrer Meinung wir
brauchen da Maß und Mitte und am Ende
das ist das was sicher eben auch gesagt
haben mehr Eigenverantwortung und im
Moment sind wir natürlich in der Phase
in der jeder eigenverantwortlich diese
Entscheidung auch treffen muss und im
Nachhinein die die Debatte über eine
Impfpflicht die ist natürlich gerade
jetzt mit heutigen Blick wie aus der
Zeit gefallen
das grausamste überhaupt an den ganzen
Maßnahmen und da spricht man natürlich
nicht von Impfpflicht aber ohne Impfung
ja
entstanden weil man sich nicht getraut
hat zu einer richtigen Impfpflicht hat
und genau
unter Druck setzt und wie viel gibt's
denn jetzt die tatsächlich Schäden haben
die aber angeben ich habe mich nur
impfen lassen weil wo sind denn jetzt
die ganzen Verantwortlichen wo sind denn
die die sich vielleicht mal
entschuldigen weil sie Druck ausgeübt
sind haben wo sind denn die Arbeitgeber
die Druck viele Mitarbeiter ausgeübt
haben auch heute noch obwohl es keine
Impfpflicht mehr gibt kennen Sie die
aktuellen Regeln der der sticko wie man
sich gerade impfen lassen muss ich kann
jetzt nicht alle Details aus dem Kopf
aber schauen Sie sich mal an es ist es
ist einfach unsinnig es ist wirklich
wirklich unsinnig und ich erwarte von
der STIKO eigentlich erwarte ich schon
lange aber ich erwarte jetzt von der
STIKO dass Sie bitte sich hinhaut und
einfach mal wieder ordentliche und dann
neue Impfempfehlung ausspricht und
deshalb ist es so wichtig dass wir
unabhängige Institute brauchen
unabhängig nicht unabhängig die ist
nicht unbedingt das Gremium und Sie
können mir nicht erzählen
soll ganz viel wir merken hier an dieser
Stelle es ist ganz viel Transparenz noch
fragt bei diesem Thema und wir merken
auch es gibt krisenkrisen Krisen ohne
Ende und über eine weitere sprechen wir
jetzt diskutieren gibt's nämlich viel
mit Schrecken sehen wir nämlich hier wie
eine große Bank in den USA zugrunde geht
und fragen uns natürlich wird diese
Bankenkrise irgendwann auch uns
erreichen und das ist jetzt das große
Thema von Herrn Röhl wir sehen in der
Schweiz passiert einiges mit der Credit
Suisse wir fragen uns natürlich
hierzulande wie können wir unser
Erspartes retten ihr Thema jetzt in
dieser Sendung unsere
Erspartes können wir natürlich am besten
dadurch retten indem wir als Einzelne
nicht auf irgendetwas fetten sondern das
machen was früher schon die
bildbörsenomi uns geraten hat breit
gestreut nie bereut das gilt eben nicht
nur für irgendwelche Aktien sondern das
gilt eben auch für Einlagen natürlich
wir haben die staatliche
Einlagensicherung in Deutschland wir
haben Sicherungssysteme der Sparkasse
der Volksbanken der Privatbanken die
oben drauf kommen keiner muss jetzt hier
Angst um sein Geld haben das ist ganz
wichtig aber man möchte ja auch immer
handlungsfähig sein egal was passiert
insofern warum nicht in zweit und
Eintritt konnte das ist das was man
praktisch tun kann als einzelner und
vielleicht auch nicht das Geld für ein
Schnaps mehr Zins gleich irgendwo in der
Weltgeschichte in andere Länder
herumschicken auch eine kurzfristige
Bundesanleihe bietet 2,8 bis 3 Prozent
in diesen Zeiten und da hat man
zumindest soliden Schuldner weil wenn
der die Grätsche macht dann gehst viel
schief gegangen ansonsten was der
Regulator natürlich tun muss er muss
klar machen dass er viel Verhalten und
Spekulation nicht duldet wir brauchen
eine starke Regulierung in den USA weil
das mit eines der Probleme dass Donald
Trump denn dort Frank mit dem Obama auf
die Finanzkrise reagiert hat hatte für
solche Regionalbanken zurückgefahren hat
und solche Regionalbanken können dann
eben sehr groß werden wie wir im Silicon
Valley gesehen haben wenn sie in
offensives Geschäftsmodell haben und wir
brauchen aber auch natürlich klare
Sanktionen wenn Fehlverhalten vorliegt
da kann ja nur hoffen dass die
Amerikaner ein klares Signal geben es
gibt Berichte darüber dass die Vorstände
der Silicon Valley Bank noch kurz vor
diesem kollaps-aktien verkauft haben
dass sie Boni verteilt haben also diese
Boni die gehören natürlich einkassiert
die Erlöser aus den Aktienverkäufen
gehören einkassiert diese Leute gehören
an den Pranger gestellt weil auch da
haben wir wieder das Thema es müssen
alle das Gefühl haben dass diejenigen
die gegen die Regeln verstoßen bestraft
werden weil sonst bricht uns das
zusammen weil Banking genau wie die
Marktwirtschaft lebt vom Vertrauen und
von mitmachen und es gibt offenbar so
höre ich raus in einigen Banken einfach
zu schlechtes Management und zu wenig
auf sich zu wenig Kontrolle ja also ich
denke wir haben in Europa eine ganze
Menge aus der Finanzkrise gelernt
natürlich könnte dann der einen oder
anderen auf sich Stelle die auf sich
denken deutlich stärker sein wir in
Deutschland haben halt wirklich auch das
Glück mit diesem drei Säulen
Bankensystem mit Sparkassen mit
Genossenschaften mit privaten
Geschäftsbanken die voneinander
unabhängig sind ja in den USA haben wir
sehr sehr viele Regionalbanken von denen
übrigens immer auch relativ viele mal
wieder pleite gegangen sind das war halt
alles sehr zersplittert aber wenn dann
so eine Regionalbank plötzlich kommt und
zu einer richtigen macht wird aber immer
noch die Regionalbanken Regulierung
nutzt dann haben wir natürlich ein
Problem und das haben wir jetzt gesehen
und das ganze kombiniert natürlich mit
einem Risikomanagement was na ja so ein
bisschen wild west oder so ein bisschen
Lachs war na also man hat ja im Silicon
Valley das Geld der einlege was im
Wesentlichen ja Technologieunternehmen
waren keine kleinen Sparer weil man
irgendwas damit machen musste als Bank
irgendwann man konnte keinen sinnvoll
ist Geschäft und machen also in
langfristige Staatsanleihen gelegt und
die haben einen Wert verloren durch den
Zins Anstieg und das ist alles nicht so
schlimm solange nicht irgendwann die
Leute an Geld wollen
würde richtig falsch gemanagt da wurden
noch Boni letzter Sekunde schnell noch
ausgezeichnet wurde
das ist moralisch das ist moralisch
verrotzt und da muss man auch sagen also
da ist auch wirklich die Frage inwieweit
Disney irgendwo aus strafrechtlich
relevant ist weil der ist ja nicht mehr
fahrlässig das ist dann das ist dann
Vorsatz also
President beiden hat ja sehr klar
erklärt dass es in der bei der Silicon
Valley Bank keine Rettung der Bank gibt
das heißt also es werden nicht die
Aktionäre und es werden nicht die
Gläubiger der Bank gerettet sondern es
werden die Einleger der Bank gerettet
ähm dann hat er gesagt der Frau
Kapitalismus ja es ist richtig so
funktioniert aber es funktioniert auch
so dass diejenigen die sich nicht an die
Regeln halten mit aller Härte dann
entsprechend bestraft werden müssen das
bedeutet auch Herr Platz 2018
auch die Banken in die Misere laufen
lassen nicht eingreifen damit sie lernen
nein das ist ja sehr schnell auch
gefährlich für die Gesellschaft für uns
alle das haben wir ja zur Zeit der
Finanzkrise auch bemerkt ich bin genau
der Meinung wie Sie dass wir auch die
Regeln hier in Europa und in Deutschland
überprüfen sollten wenn sich mal
anschaut jemand der einen Kredit
bekommen möchte von einer Bank der muss
heute relativ viel Eigenkapital
mitbringen meistens 20 30 Prozent
mindestens und die Banken selber
brauchen für ihre Geschäfte nur ganz
ganz wenig Eigenkapital das stimmt doch
irgendwas nicht und daher müssten wir
auch hier die Regeln straffen und
brauchen dringend auch eine Diskussion
darüber damit uns nicht so etwas blüht
was wir vor 14 15 Jahren hier in
Deutschland erlebt haben denn am Ende
gibt ja immer ein der dann alles
bezahlen muss und das war in der
Vergangenheit am meistens der
Steuerzahler genau der Staat und dann
der Steuerzahler wir stellen Sie sich
das vorher herum was könnte man da
verändern also sie muss es muss ganz
klar diese Trennlinie gezogen werden im
Zweifelsfall gibt es eine Garantie für
die Spareinlagen da muss man sicherlich
auch den einen oder anderen in die
Mithaftung nehmen also warum die
amerikanische Einlagensicherung jetzt
jedem Unternehmen das sagen ja teilweise
100% seiner Mittel bei einer einzigen
Bank angelegt hat also auch so
Risikomanagement bei yupid Betrieben hat
in dieser
wolkigen Startup Welt das zu 100% wieder
ersetzt das weiß ich nicht also Rocco so
eine Person notierte swimmingplattform
hat von 460 Millionen Dollar 126
Millionen bei der Bank gehabt naja also
die gehen jetzt nicht pleite wenn sie
nicht die Fallen 126 drücken also da
müsste man auch schon da Eigentum
verpflichtet zur Diversifikation zur
Streuung die müsste man zumindest einmal
auch ein bisschen in die Mithaftung
nehmen aber ansonsten ganz klar wir
müssen äh dann um auch künftige Krisen
zu verhindern und das hat beiden mit
dieser schnellen Reaktion deutlich
gemacht zeigt übrigens auch wie eng die
Sache wahrscheinlich
war es werden Einleger gerettet in dem
Umfang dass sie nicht ein existenziellen
Schaden daraus erleichtern viele auch ob
das irgendwie zu uns rüber schreibt ich
habe gerade gesagt jetzt wackelt die
Credit Suisse und viele denken ich hebe
lieber alles ganz schnell ab ab in den
Sparstrumpf wieder zurück und das
Kopfkissen hauptsache ich habe nicht
mehr irgendwo auf der Bank was liegen
was sagen sie zu sehr also Situationen
wenn das wenn das alle machen dann ist
das genauso wie die nächste Finanzkrise
existiert wir hatten so eine Situation
2018 sind an einem Wochenende als ich
abzeichnete das ist Montag eventuell aus
Grund der Angst der Leute vor dieser
Finanzkrise an solchen Bank Run geben
könnte sind per Steinbrück und Frau
Merkels Bundeskanzlerin vor die Presse
gegangen gesagt wir ähm garantieren die
Sicherheit ihrer spracheinlagen das war
nur ein narrativ das war ja keine
wirksame Garantie zu sagen das Parlament
für entscheidend
das ist das ist wichtig dass auch das
alle wissen wir haben ja jetzt keine
Situation wie niemand es kippeln hier
keine deutschen Banken und dass die
Credit Swiss kippelt ist die Folge von
jahrelang wirklich
jahrelangemanagement und das kündigt
sich ja nun schon seit ein paar Monaten
an und wir müssen ja eigentlich davon
ausgehen mit dem vorlaufen das
Notenbanken und Regierungen da
irgendwelche Notfallpläne in der Tasche
haben nur wenn die Frage kommt rutschen
wir jetzt auch in eine Finanzkrise es
wäre natürlich absolut töricht zu sagen
nein weil wir wissen ja gar nicht was da
verborgen ist was da irgendwo gerade bei
der kreditsu ist in irgendwelchen
Derivate Bilanzen oder sonst was noch
drin steckt vielleicht wissen sie selber
auch noch gar nicht so genau sie haben
ja gerade bei ihrem Jahresabschluss
gesagt na dann müssen wir noch mal ein
bisschen nachrechnen wir uns noch nicht
so oder damit rauszugehen aber wichtig
ist auch hier wieder es geht um das
Vertrauen der Kreislauf muss am Laufen
gehalten werden die Banken müssen sich
untereinander Vertrauen damit sie im
interbanken beschäftigt zumindest
overnight Geschäfte dann machen können
und natürlich auch die Menschen müssen
den Banken Vertrauen das dieses Thema
sicher sind dieses System sind sicher
kennen das Vertrauen da ist und das
heißt aber auch dass man sich als Teil
dieses Systems fühlt manche Menschen
haben aber vielleicht auch den Eindruck
ist regiert oft die Gier Herr geht ihnen
so als ich da was verändert in unserer
Gesellschaft das vielleicht der ein oder
andere auch gieriger geworden ist
ja tatsächlich ich habe schon den
Eindruck kann ich das nur wieder
kovi sagen das ist ja das beste Beispiel
für mich nämlich die Profiteure der
Pandemie und es ist nichts anderes als
Puri Gier ja also nicht ich habe zuvor
angesprochen wenn Impfärzte ihre
beziehungsweise ihre Tätigkeit in den
Krankenhäusern und so einfach lassen und
Urlaub nehmen damit man in der
Impfzentren geht dann unterstelle ich
jetzt einfach bei den meisten dass das
nicht passiert weil sie sagen wir müssen
jetzt unbedingt die
Pandemie beenden sondern ganz einfach
weil das Geld im Hintergrund steht
nämlich der Stundenlohn und den kenne
ich sehr wohl und da würden sie jetzt
alle hier blass werden wenn ich das
erzählen würde was man da pro Stunde
bekommt also
zum Beispiel mir hat man in der Stunde
220 Euro angeboten zu impfen an sondern
Feiertagen mehr und jetzt rechnen Sie
das mal aus wenn Sie das täglich machen
und es vielleicht mal für zwei Wochen
dann haben sie ein nettes sümpchen
beieinander das gleiche geht für die
Testzentren die Testzentren haben sich
unter also garantiert einige dumm und
dämlich verdient um das mal so zu sagen
und das ganze narrativ der Angst wurde
aufrechte halten warum aber da keiner
interessiert dass das wieder abnimmt
weil man einfach nichts mehr verdient
und ich finde schon ja die hier
insgesamt hat zugenommen aber das kann
man ja auch weiter ausdehnen ist nicht
nur die normale Bevölkerung ist in der
auch die Politiker z.B ich denke jetzt
mal bei unserem Bayern die Masken Affäre
ja dass man Masken irgendwie das ist
doch nicht also ich finde es aber falsch
dem einzelnen dir vorzuwerfen wenn es
doch es war doch genau Zweck davon man
wollte möglichst schnell ist sie finden
es falsch aber es war doch der Sinn
davon möglichst schnell Masken zu
bekommen und möglichst schnell viele
Leute zu impfen dann hat doch haben doch
die Verantwortlichen die diese Anreize
gesetzt haben haben dafür gesorgt dass
es funktioniert und natürlich wenn man
mir 300 Euro die Stunde für was bietet
was ich kann und mache überlege ich mir
das natürlich auch sofort es zu tun das
ist doch keine gear das ist doch ganz
normal
das Verhalten gewesen
ich sehe das als Arzt anders da den da
muss ich einfach meinem ärztlichen
Gewissen und meiner Überzeugung folgen
und das hoffe ich dass es vielleicht für
andere Berufsgruppen auch noch gilt sie
sehen also liebe ZuschauerInnen ganz
schnell auch wieder bei dem Thema Corona
gleich jetzt hier aber nach einer kurzen
Pause weiter mit dem deutschen
vielleicht liebsten Thema das Auto das
ist aber in Gefahr bleiben Sie dran bis
gleich
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren so viertel nach acht wir haben
viel gesprächsstoffe wirklich sein das
ist doch völlig Realität fertig ich
finde unheimlich wichtig
vielleicht muss ich doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht ruinieren
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glückler
und der Bruder sich optisch ein bisschen
angepasst
haben wir haben zu viel Stahl wegfallen
und wir uns gegenseitig in Berlin Mitte
Cappuccinos verkaufen das funktioniert
nicht dann ist mit Wohlstand
das muss jedem erlaubt sein
wenn ihr Opfer und um Währungen von
Menschen in unserem Land fordert dann
müsst ihr bei euch anfangen ich finde
aber diese gesamte Debatte die wir auch
fühlen auch ein bisschen verrückt das
ist nicht aufgearbeitet und das müssen
wir noch machen und das ist leider
Gottes auch ein Punkt mit dem Bericht
[Musik]
da sind wir wieder zurück bei 8:15 Uhr
das Auto ist in Gefahr ab 2030 heißt es
Schluss mit dem Verbrenner Christoph
Ploß der Chef der Hamburger CDU der will
das Auto retten Stichwort efuels und das
ist jetzt ihr Thema ja wir hoffentlich
gegen das geplante Verbrenner Verbot
wird und sich für technologieoffenheit
einsetzt gegen den nehmen im Moment Hass
und Hetze aus dem linken politischen
Spektrum zu
die politische Linke möchte unbedingt
das Verbrennerauto verbieten es sollen
keine Autos mit Verbrennungsmotor ab
2035 mehr zugelassen werden und das
Verbot halten wir als CDU für falsch
gerade weil die Motoren auch mit
klimaneutralen Kraftstoffen wie efuels
betrieben werden könnten und man auch
zum Beispiel mit efuels die Klimaziele
erreichen kann und man sieht bei dieser
Debatte sehr schön etwas was wir eben
auch schon bei der Debatte über die
Heizung gesehen haben nämlich dass im
Moment grüne und Sozialdemokraten auf
europäischer Ebene aber auch im
Deutschen Bundestag nicht nur die
Klimaziele festlegen wollen sondern auf
vorschreiben wollen auf welchem Wege
Unternehmen und Verbraucher diese Ziele
erreichen sollen es soll nur noch eine
Technologie zum Einsatz kommen beim Auto
ist es das Batterie getriebene
Elektroauto beim Heizen ist es die
Wärmepumpe und ich werbe dafür dass wir
technologieoffen sind und dass wir den
Menschen überlassen welche Technologien
und Ansätze am besten sind und dazu
gehört auch dass das klimaneutrale
Verbrennerauto auch in Zukunft erlaubt
sich aus das heißt also vom E-Auto höre
ich raus und sie jetzt nicht unbedingt
der größte Fan was haben Sie denn ich
habe gar nichts gegen das eher oder das
gibt in Großstädten durchaus Sinn dass
Ihr Auto einzusetzen ich bin aber sehr
dafür dass nicht die Politik vorschreibt
das ist nur noch eine Form des Autos in
Zukunft geben darf sondern ich bin dafür
dass es unterschiedliche Ansätze gibt
unterschiedliche Technologien wir wissen
heute auch noch gar nicht welche
Technologien ist in fünf Jahren oder in
zehn Jahren vielleicht besonders
effizient oder klimafreundlich da kann
sich ja in der Forschung noch ganz viel
ergeben und deswegen wäre es falsch
heute von oben vorzuschreiben das ist
nur noch eine Technologie in Zukunft
geben soll und wir haben hier auch noch
ein weiteren wichtigen mit denen ich
gerne einmal anführen möchte weil sich
wahrscheinlich auf viele Zuschauer
Fragen dann hätte ich bald die Heizung
auswechseln ich habe mir vor kurzem ein
neues Auto angeschafft und muss das
möglicherweise auch wieder austauschen
und das finde ich geht nicht und
deswegen müssen wir auch dringend die
Preise bei Autos beim Heizen im Blick
haben und warum soll ein klimaneutraler
Verbrenner der möglicherweise sehr
günstig hergestellt werden kann verboten
werden dafür gibt es überhaupt keine
Argumente außer Ideologie und ich bin
dafür dass wir bei der ganzen
Klimadiskussion viel mehr über das
erlauben sprechen und weniger über das
verbieten also ihr Autos vielleicht aber
auch zu teuer wenn man sagt für die
breite genau am Ende am Ende muss das in
der Sozialen Marktwirtschaft der Markt
entscheiden also es wird sicherlich
Batterie getriebene Elektroautos geben
und es gibt viele Argumente die auch
dafür sprechen aber es gibt sehr viele
in Deutschland also BMW zum Beispiel
porsche hat das gerade diese Woche
gesagt viele Zulieferer Bosch da hängen
ja übrigens auch sehr sehr viele
Arbeitsplätze in Deutschland dran die
sagen wir können den Verbrenner
klimadotraum machen oder wir wollen zum
Beispiel auch auf Wasserstoff setzen im
PKW Bereich bMW hat das gerade vor
kurzem noch mal gesagt warum sollte der
Staat oder die Politik verbieten dass
diese Ansätze zum Tragen kommen wenn
damit sogar die Klimaziele erreicht
werden und deswegen mein Plädoyer lass
doch auch in ein Wettbewerb der um die
besten Ansätze gehen da muss ich am
Markt dann der richtige Ansatz
durchsetzen am Ende ist es für die
Verbraucher immer am günstigsten wenn
sie auch eine Auswahl haben und nicht
wenn der Staat von oben voll schreibt
nur eine Technologie
vielen Dank Herr Kollege ich habe nur
eine ganz kurze Frage sie haben gesagt
dass man so vielen Ländern schon tanken
kann können Sie mir denn sagen in
welchen Ländern tatsächlich getankt wird
schauen Sie schauen Sie nur in die
europäische Nachbarstaaten jetzt fehlt
mir die Redezeit die alle aufzuführen
aber ich schicke Ihnen gerne ich schicke
Ihnen gerne eine Grafik so hier aber
haben sie die Redezeit oder vielleicht
der Grafik und hier wollen wir noch
einmal jetzt können sie groß reinmachen
und können sagen wo gibt es das wo
gibt's diese Technologie wie schnell
bringen wir die hierher gibt es eine
Grafik oder zumindest wir haben ja bei
der Debatte darüber gesprochen ob in
Zukunft der Vertrieb von den efues also
das sind Kraftstoffe die auf Strom
basieren und die am Ende ein
klimaneutralen Prozess darstellen also
man braucht für die Produktion CO2 dann
wird CO2 ausgestoßen am Ende ist der
Prozess Klima neutral da ist der
Vertrieb an Tankstellen im Moment in
Deutschland untersagt in den meisten
europäischen Staaten beispielsweise in
Schweden beispielsweise in Polen ist der
Vertrieb erlaubt erlaubt wir sind da
noch in einem sehr sehr frühen Stadium
also es gibt natürlich noch keinen
Massenmarkt für die eu- aber viele
Unternehmen sagen wir wären in paar
Jahren in der Lage viel mehr evolutes
auf dem Markt zu bringen und damit auch
den Verbrennungsmotor klimaneutral
betreiben zu können und deswegen wollte
ich noch mal das auch aufgreifen was ich
eben gesagt habe warum soll denn die
Politik dann so etwas verbieten wir
können das doch wir können das doch auch
erlauben und das hat man eben ja bei
diesem kurzen Ausschnitt auch gesehen
die Grünen sperren sich massiv dagegen
dass das überhaupt erlaubt wird ich weiß
nicht welche Technologie sich
durchsetzen wird aber ich bin sehr dafür
dass wir alles zulassen und am Ende
Forscher Unternehmen die Verbraucher
entscheiden auf was sie setzen wollen
haben Sie das Gefühl wir sind da in
Deutschland zu technikfeindlich wir
haben gerade darüber geredet porsche hat
jetzt eine fusionwerk in Südamerika
gebaut die Grünen sind dagegen stimmen
dieser Technologie noch nicht so richtig
zu sind wir da nicht wie Herr bloss ist
fordert fortschrittlich genug trauen wir
uns ja zu wenig also ich kenne speziell
für uns nicht sagen weil ich kann keinen
Physiker bin was Wirkungsgrad für so
angeht wovon ich keine Ahnung ob sei
nichts aber ansonsten bin ich da völlig
bei Ihnen warum machen wir das ganze
nicht als Wettbewerb der Industrie wir
haben so großartige Ingenieure hier im
Land und das ist ja auch das ist ja auch
ein tolles Ziel hier geht es ja nicht
daraus darum irgendwie noch mal
irgendwie so ein so fünf Prozent mehr
Leistung aus einem Motor raus zu kitzeln
sondern wir reden immer so abstrakt über
Klimaziele sowas aber wir haben am Ende
haben wir doch ein ganz großes Ziel da
oben sie haben das Ziel sogar vorne in
der Parteien drin das C die Bewahrung
des Schöpfung das ist doch das was wir
was wir erreichen wollen und dafür mit
unserem Genius und diesen
technologischen Möglichkeiten alles zu
mobilisieren das ist doch eine ganz
großartige Herausforderung die er
vielleicht auch Menschen junge Menschen
dazu bringt eben nicht BWL zu studieren
sondern vielleicht Ingenieur zu werden
und an diesen Lösungen mitzuarbeiten
weil das sind Lösungen für Generation
ich glaube das ist wichtig diesen
Wettbewerb auch zu organisieren von
staatlicher Seite und zu orchestrieren
durchaus auch zu fördern aber auch da
wieder dieses Thema milestones ja wir
brauchen schon als Staat irgendwie ein
commitment das haben wir mit diesen
Klimazielen ich glaube die sollten wir
runterbrechen und wir sollten gerade
wenn wir bei Mobilität gehen also auch
wenn ich hier selber in Berlin Mitte
leben Freunde in ganz Deutschland
sollten aufhören das geht jetzt
insbesondere auch wieder an die Adresse
diejenigen derjenigen die lieber Verbote
Politik machen als über das Fordern und
Fördern
Mobilität aus dieser Berlin-Mitte Blase
ist das einfachste ganz aufs Auto zu
verzichten könnten sie das ja ich mach
das ich mache das ich habe ich hätte
früher zwei Autos als in Berlin gekommen
bin 2000 12 habe 2015 das größere mit
blutendem Herzen als BMW Fan verkauft
überstanden 2019 haben wir den Mini von
meiner Frau auch verkauft bewegen und
seitdem mit Carsharing und öffent
öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln hier und
wenn man dann doch mal irgendwie zur Oma
und Opa an einer Thüringen fahren dann
mieten wir uns halt ein Auto das
funktioniert ganz wunderbar nur ich kann
doch dass das für mich funktioniert mir
macht das Spaß ich sehe das als Luxus
dass ich kein Auto brauche und dass ich
mich kümmern muss und sonst was obwohl
ich früher Autos geliebt habe aber ich
kann doch daraus das Tier ja
natürlich wie oft ist ich habe das dann
irgendwie bei mir draußen vor der Tür
stehen gehabt wie oft in den Jahren die
Polizei geklingelt hat ist auf meine
Straße ja wir müssen es umsetzen da sind
Baumaßnahmen oder abgesperrt oder sonst
was wenn man sich dann nicht drüber
ich glaube das Land von mir aufgreifen
das sind ganz ganz wichtiger auch bei
der Diskussion auch bei anderen
Diskussionen wir erleben gerade bei den
Grünen und auch bei der SPD dass die
entscheiden wollen wie die Bürger leben
und gerade wenn ich an den ländlichen
Raum denke da sind ja viele die auch
entfernt sind von der Großstadt von der
Uhren S-Bahn Station
Berlin Mitte heraus es wird nur Politik
gemacht sondern ländlichen Raum also
ähm nein meine Mutter lebt in der
Metropolregion Rhein-Ruhr auch Ruhrpott
genannt ja äh ist von Essen früher ins
Krankenhaus bis nach Datteln Gefahren ja
das können sie nicht mit dem
öffentlichen machen da sind sie
zweieinhalb Stunden statt einer
unterwegs
nach Selbstbestimmung und nicht nur der
Vorgabe quasi von oben ist hier an
vielen Stellen ganz groß morgen ist bei
uns Hannes Rast sogar er ist
Bürgermeister von Schönau am Königssee
und er schlägt er landen in seinem
kleinen Ort sollen hunderte Flüchtlinge
untergebracht werden er hat dafür
bereits ein Ferienheim ein früheres
angemietet weiß aber nicht wie er das
alles umsetzen soll sie Herr Gräber sie
haben genau zu diesem Thema tief
recherchiert sie sagen über ortskräfte
aus Afghanistan jetzt beispielsweise
kommen auch Islamisten ins Land und sie
sagen auch wir müssen dringend an
unseren asylgesetzen Arbeiten ihr Thema
genau das sind eigentlich zwei Themen
die aber natürlich eng miteinander
zusammenhängen das eine sind die
Migranten wir sind hier im Bild die und
in lebensgefährlichen Situation sich
begeben um zu uns nach Europa kommen und
dort vor allem auch oft nach Deutschland
dort sind die Zahlen wieder gestiegen
und vor allem aus Afghanistan sind dort
auch wieder sehr viele Migranten dabei
die bei uns illegal einwandern
eigentlich meistens kein Asylrecht
wirklich haben aber trotzdem bei uns
bleiben weil sie nicht abgeschoben
werden
gleichzeitig und das ist das Thema was
ich zusammen mit dem Kollegen Ulrich
Thiele bei Cicero recherchiert habe und
wo wir auch noch nach wie vor dran sind
macht die Bundesregierung gerade ein
Aufnahmeprogramm wo sie noch mal
zusätzlich bis zu 1.000 Afghanen im
Monat von Afghanistan direkt nach
Deutschland holt und wir haben
herausgefunden dass deutsche
Sicherheitsbehörden da schon seit
einiger Zeit massivste Bedenken haben
wen wir uns da ins Land holen und jetzt
ist aktuell eine Warnung aus der
deutschen Botschaft bekannt geworden das
für ein Spezialfall wo wo Juristen
geholt werden sollen dass dort etliche
sogenannte Scharia Richter darunter sind
also Islamisten die ja sozusagen das
islamische Rechtsverständnis nach
Deutschland bringen und ich glaube
spätestens daher doch das Verständnis in
der Bevölkerung dafür auf was diese
Bundesregierung da eigentlich treibt
das sind Thema sind viele Informationen
also Scharia Richter bekommen Asyl in
Deutschland es ist kein Asyl es ist eine
eine humanitäre Aufnahme weil
argumentiert wird es geht eigentlich
also das Programm ist natürlich nicht
für Scharia Richter eigentlich gedacht
so Juristen für für Richter zum Beispiel
die dort dem Westen geholfen haben ist
Afghanistan westliches
Justizsystem aufzubauen und den jetzt
angeblich die Verfolgung durch die
Taliban tot nur die Leute die sich dort
tatsächlich melden in den
botschafterbrief heißt es wir sind
mehrere hundert und errechnet ungefähr
die Hälfte davon sein Leute die mit den
Teilnehmern eigentlich überhaupt keine
Probleme haben weil sie das selber
Gedankengut teilen und ihre westliche
justizausbildung Crashkurs war aber sie
eigentlich an an ist islamischen Recht
ausgebildet wurden und das ist was was
irgendwie wirklich also ich glaube auf
diese Leute sollten wir wirklich
verzichten welche Forderungen leiten sie
wir daraus ab sie sagen die EU sollte
Ihre Außengrenzen besser sichern wie
kann das funktionieren aus ihrer Sicht
nee darüber reden wir ja schon seit 2015
seit 2016
das Europa offensichtlich nicht dazu in
der Lage ist das Problem der illegalen
Migration wo man auch Härte zeigen muss
also es wird dann immer gewarnt vor der
Festung Europa und vorabschottung und zu
harten Maßnahmen natürlich sollen diese
diese Schiffe nicht im Mittelmeer
versenkt werden oder die Leute man muss
sich natürlich helfen aber man muss sie
nicht nach Europa bringen und so lange
das nicht funktioniert müsste weg
zumindest Deutschland auch dahin kommen
und sagen da müssen wir eben unsere
Grenzen schützen aber darüber reden wir
seit 2015 und es passiert nicht was
glauben Sie sie haben quasi sein selbst
zwei Themen heute mitgebracht zum einen
geht es um strengere Asylgesetze zum
anderen geht es um ihre eigenen
Recherche
darum dass Juristen sogenannte Juristen
nach Deutschland aus Afghanistan kommen
sollen der viele davon eben eine Schar
glauben und nicht unbedingt an westliche
Gesetze was glauben Sie was muss
passieren dass da auch mehr Transparenz
reinkommt dass man mehr darüber Bescheid
weiß wer auch ins Land kommt also ich
glaube zunächst mal ist dieses
Aufnahmeprogramm wo unter anderem die
Juristen mit reinkommen aber nicht nur
die es geht auch um
Menschenrechtsaktivisten und und sowas
ich dieses Programm wurde ja gestartet
als noch nicht klar war dass die
illegale Migration wieder so hoch geht
wie jetzt ich glaube im jetzigen Moment
müsste man dieses Programm einfach
stoppen und auch es ist auf komplett
fehl konstruiert weil die
Bundesregierung damit entschied aus
zusammenarbeitet die die Vorauswahl vor
Ort machen die wirklich teilweise links
radikale Ziele verfolgen nämlich eine
Welt komplett ohne Grenzen und und eine
Idee die die einfach
nicht realistisch sind und die auch
gefährlich sind letztendlich ich glaube
dieses Programm ist von vorne bis hinten
falsch konzipiert müsste gestoppt werden
und das andere ist natürlich auch die
illegale Migration muss begrenzt werden
sie nicken 2015 sagte noch ihre
Kanzlerin wir schaffen das glauben Sie
jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt wäre das ein
Satz den man wiederholen könnte also ich
geh ja zur jüngeren Generationen in der
CDU und ich habe 2015 und das was da
auch politisch entschieden wurde immer
sehr kritisch gesehen weil ich immer
gesagt habe wir müssen illegale
Migration stoppen und wir müssen vor
allem auch schon an den europäischen
Außengrenzen kontrollieren wer zu uns
reinkommt nur so können wir auch
innerhalb der Europäischen Union und
innerhalb Europas die Grenzen offen
halten wenn wir schon an den
europäischen Außengrenzen genau
kontrollieren wird für uns reinkommt und
dann muss in weiterer Grundsatz gelten
der ist enorm wichtig auch mit Blick auf
Integrationsprobleme die wir hier in
Berlin aber auch in anderen Großstädten
sehen wer ist nach Deutschland kommt der
muss die deutschen Werte akzeptieren der
muss unsere Kultur akzeptieren der muss
bereit sein sich zu integrieren und wer
das nicht ist der muss sich ein anderes
Land suchen das also ihr Fazit Herr
Röders ist immer ganz schwer bei so
einem Thema über Zahlen zu reden weil
wir über Menschen reden gleichzeitig
haben wir hier in dieser Sendung auch so
viel über Zahlen gesprochen die
Sozialabgaben in Deutschland sind
wahnsinnig hoch die Staatsquote bei fast
50 Prozent und daher möchte ich Ihnen
diese brutale Frage stellen wie viel
kann man sich leisten wie viel können
wir geben
Bundespräsident hat mir gesagt die Liebe
in unseren Herzen ist endlich nicht aber
alles andere ist eben eine ist eben doch
dann endlich und da müssen wir haben
begrenzter Ressourcen sofern bin ich
sehr gespannt auf Ihre Interview mit dem
Bürgermeister weil die Kommunen müssen
das ja finanziell und auch von der
Integration her aus Baden und dann
gestalten wir müssen hier bezahlen
sprechen aber wenn wir bezahlen sprechen
müssen wir glaube ich nicht immer nur so
die einzelte Themen nehmen wie hier in
Asyl wie da ein Programm sondern wir
müssen insgesamt über das Thema
Deutschland als Einwanderungsland
sprechen und auch da wirklich einen
großen Entwurf haben also wir können
nicht einfach sagen naja wir brauchen
Einwanderung für unsere Sozialsysteme
Volk ich machen wir jetzt ganz viele von
diesen Programmen die Sie hier zitiert
haben so wird es nicht funktionieren da
brauchen wir strategischen Entwurf wie
das denn aussieht bitte mit Deutschland
als Einwanderungsland so dass das auch
dann wirklich ein positiven Beitrag zu
den Sozialsystem bringt und wir brauchen
ja qualifizierte Kräfte wir brauchen
Facharbeiter wir brauchen qualifizierte
Einwanderung nur das heißt natürlich
auch dass wir bereit sind zu akzeptieren
dass Deutschland an einen wanderungsland
ist und dann müssen wir dafür auch
entsprechende Bedingungen machen müssen
Menschen aber auch entsprechende
Angebote machen könnte ich sagen ja gut
also ihr könnt jetzt mal kommen und dann
gehen wir euch ein bisschen Geld und
dann müsst ihr halt ihr irgendwo vorhin
leben die Einwanderung also das wird
immer so vermischt in der deutschen
Debatte es ist doch jedes
funktionierende Einwanderungsland hat
doch ein ganz striktes grenzkriterium
also natürlich Kriterien dann wenn wir
das machen wir doch gerade zu uns kommt
der nach wie vor kommt seit 2015 jeder
ins Land der ist bis zur deutschen
Grenze schafft das ist ja auch zynisch
weil das schaffen nur die die Stärkeren
und jüngeren meistens Männer
und dort das Wort Asyl ausspricht dann
ist der bei uns im System und bleibt
meistens wird er nicht abgeschoben
selbst wenn er eigentlich nach dem Recht
gar keine Asylrecht hat und liegt in
vielen Fällen wenn er nicht arbeitet
natürlich auch dem Sozialsystem auf den
Taschen das ist doch eigentlich genau
das Gegenteil von der Einwanderung von
der sie genau genau wir brauchen das ist
völlig logisch wir müssen Einwanderung
wirklich als äh Strategie für eine
Gesellschaft denken die Bereiche sind
also nicht finanziell oder
wirtschaftlichen sondern also auch
kulturell extrem
bereichernd ist nur das das heißt es
auch nicht nur immer als
gnadenaktien und deswegen die Grenzen
und gleichzeitig beispielsweise das
kleine Dorf schönere den Realität Schock
ich weiß dass sie als Arzt der sich das
zur Lebensaufgabe gemacht hat den
Menschen zu helfen sicherlich aber auch
Schwierigkeiten dann sehen wenn ein
Bürgermeister um Hilfe ruft und sagt ich
kann das gar nicht schaffen wir helfen
gerne ich miete ja alles an aber morgen
sitze hier in der Sendung mit ihm
Gespräche geführt und er sagt ich weiß
nicht wie ich das schaffen kann wie geht
es Ihnen mit diesem Zwiespalt
also ich habe ja die die
2015 auch miterlebt eben schon im
Öffentlichen Gesundheitsdienst ich
konnte also beobachten wie viel Menschen
zu uns kamen wie die Aufnahmesituation
war aber auch gesehen wie die
wie die Aufnahmen laufen ja und da da
hat man schon also ich hatte da schon
Sorge dass hier das System also unser
System ganz einfach versagt und da war
nichts mit also nach meinem Eindruck wir
schaffen das denn man wusste aber im
gewissen Zeitpunkt nicht mehr wo
irgendwo jemand ist die
die Asylsuchenden die die waren einmal
hier dann waren sie einmal dort also man
konnte das überhaupt gar nicht mehr
nicht mehr nachvollziehen und es war
auch gar nicht politische Wille so mein
Eindruck dass die Bürgermeister die
Landräte dieses Problem offen ansprechen
ja jetzt traut man sich vielleicht ganz
einfach deshalb weil man jetzt Sorge hat
das plötzlich die Bürger sagen halt
stopp wir können nicht mehr wir können
nicht mehr helfen und wir können das
auch nicht mehr tragen und es ist der
ganze gefährliche Situation denn ich
finde natürlich auch das mit den
Menschen helfen muss aber ich gebe Ihnen
vollkommen recht
man braucht komplett anderes Verfahren
aber ich bin jetzt zu wenig bewandert in
diesem Verfahren dass ich da jetzt
sofort der Lösung parat hätte aber so
wird es jetzt gerade ist finde ich
tatsächlich schrecklich ich habe nur die
Sorge dass der ganz was anderes dahinter
steckt nämlich sie haben es angesprochen
wir wollen den Fachkräftemangel decken
und beheben und das sehe ich jetzt zum
Beispiel in den Krankenhäusern welche
Auswirkungen das hat denn da gibt es
nämlich Pflegekräfte und da gibt es auch
Ärzte die und das sage ich jetzt einfach
mal so ganz brutal nicht des Deutschen
so mächtig sind dass sie den Patienten
verstehen und der Patient aber den Arzt
für die Pflegekraft und das ist aber was
absolut wichtig ganz großes Thema dass
wir hier in dieser Sendung auch schon
einmal ganz eindringliche besprochen
haben ich danke ganz herzlich an meine
Gäste danke dass ihr vollzählig bis zum
Ende der Sendung bei mir sind vielen
Dank für diese Debatte für diese
transparente für diese offene Debatte
und ganz herzlichen Dank auch an sie
fürs zuschauen machen das gut bis bald
[Musik]